entonces que representa esta nueva
visita de altos funcionarios
estadounidenses a taiwán el gobierno
chino puede intensificar estos
ejercicios militares con fuego real
hola qué tal no no creo que el gobierno
chino haga más virulentos ataques y creo
que eeuu ha encontrado un sistema de
respuestas políticas enviando
legisladores que pone muy nervioso al
gobierno chino decir estos vídeos
encontrado por fin una estrategia que no
es militar es política y que está
sacando a su rival chino de la línea
mostrando que no solo tiene buenas
intenciones para el mundo sino que está
respondiendo en forma violenta y militar
porque esta respuesta desafiante
profesores de parte de los legisladores
demócratas que van hacia taiwán digamos
que dice el gobierno central de eeuu
bueno efectivamente es una delegación
parlamentaria
ustedes saben que esta opción es un país
republicano donde el presidente no le da
órdenes al congreso entonces es un gesto
político en además que también tenemos
bases internas por ejemplo las propias
elecciones norteamericanas donde los
legisladores renuevan sus bancas y están
mostrando el liderazgo internacional
pero yo diría que estos niños lo hacen
con un gesto de apoyo a taiwán y un
gesto de decirle a los chicos pero
también a sus propios aliados que está
en la zona y que es un actor que va a
seguir estando presente fernando también
le quería preguntar si a lo mejor otros
gobiernos otros países occidentales se
enviarían digamos delegaciones
diplomáticas en esta misma línea como la
que está siendo eeuu hasta ahora
eso se está anunciando algunos países
por ejemplo japón algún país europeos
han insinuado que también lo van a hacer
yo creo que es lo que da este taiwán
comienza a tener un papel preponderante
este enfrentamiento por el poder global
entre estos dueños de china y yo creo
que lo positivo es que estos países
están haciendo gestos políticos envían
parlamentarios no hablamos del tratado
de armas y de misiles ni de bombas sino
de hombres que a centro hombres y
mujeres que hacen política y yo creo que
esto es un gesto y creo que los chinos
el gobierno chino debería responder con
proporcionalidad claro profesor pero
porque digamos en este momento
específico
bueno evidentemente el viaje de nancy
pelosi
fue evaluado positivamente puedo ver
estos nidos en generar un impacto
recuperado iniciativa política ha sacado
un poco el la lente del conflicto de
ucrania para ponerlo en un lugar que les
interesa a los eeuu así que lo que ha
hecho fue repetir la receta que ellos
consideraron exitosa algo normal en
cualquier otra actividad